[Music]
and come at me bro news come at me bro
so many by it's almost Christmas oh my
god I can't wait oh my god oh my god
it's beginning to look like we I only
like Thanksgiving Christmas
every other holiday fuck'em you hate
Halloween I don't care about how
Halloween last year four years ago with
Muriel really does it hope you think I'm
interested first Autopia are you worried
I was up from I was Russell from up
because I just look just like him so it
wasn't much of a dress up I know she was
Go Go Tomago from big hero 6 yeah but
she was gogo Tomago before that movie
came out so nobody know who the [ __ ] she
was she just looked like some j-pop girl
even better yeah and she was like I made
a mistake I thought I thought you're
talking about egg sushi that is what her
name is basically all okay I'm a Labor
Day Memorial Day kinda got myself
Bobby cute it was my turn I like New
Year's
I like st. Patrick's Day oh yes because
you like to pinch people do you guys
celebrate a 4th of July hardcore hello
you've came to all of our [ __ ] for
the July festivities stupid
you've brought the [ __ ] your
world-famous mac and cheese another time
you made your world famous usually do
fourth of July pretty hard we don't do
it the fourth of July fourth of July
like we do we make up our own cuz photos
I isn't about politics is more about
lighting their Street on fire but that's
true that's how hard we go he's in my
neighborhood it's fourth of July every
[ __ ] night that's right it's been a
while that we haven't done a fourth of
July since your other house so it's our
fault coming yeah
so it's our fault we'll be it's because
your place was a huge one floor area
they have a huge space too we're gonna
like that bye people
hey Geo I can host there who are you
talking about I'll host you I have to
ask at to invite you to invite me to go
to Thanksgiving that's true that is
right that they offered for something
you know I invited you to invite me
we got we're still enough we got away
look cuz you're always bitching about
parking at my place I'm like almost as a
threat send out mass text every holiday
someone sent out a text the reason why I
haven't sent a message for this
Thanksgiving is cuz I'm waiting on David
to tell me this mom is dead
so what are you gonna do it's your mom
and we're supposed to go to Brandon's
for Thanksgiving no we're not
you weren't even part of that
conversation we talked I was a part of
this conversation too though he said
that his mom was good my mom got down
because we have three dogs yeah but he
was gonna do it at his house your place
we thought was too tiny I was here for
this it's just I'm small right so then
we were saying you might have to do
separate things give us a meeting
between that means it's not happening
got it I don't know I just offered my
place I don't know what's happening wait
you said that you're not gonna do yours
anymore no I am but then I everybody's
here there's Thanksgiving so I wanted to
combine it but it would work if your
mom's not invited the whole thing I know
we all wanted to be together and she's
preventive we'll just have to do it
Thanksgiving battles and we'll just take
pictures of food Seibu what this shows
like too many people no because she has
three dogs with her wait do they have to
be indoors they do have a patio does she
really celebrate Thanksgiving for
Thanksgiving or she just trying to be
close to you because that could happen a
day or two you know she's care our
Thanksgiving has always been with a lot
of other people and Families cuz you
know back in Houma Sacramento we just
have a big house so it's a patio those
dogs those dogs are [ __ ] wait where
were you guys when he had Thanksgiving
last year we went to your place once
remember what year it was like a couple
year and we watched Conan yeah Conan the
Barbarian
to it three years ago yeah well last
year I was there buddy were there yeah
it was small
Julia stopped by you yeah yeah maybe you
guys were out of town or something I
don't know it was it was two years ago
last year I did in Sacramento I remember
oh that's what we didn't go yeah now she
was a [ __ ] whose house are we going to
you know I don't know I just want to
know what the [ __ ] this articles about
nah nah [ __ ] that [ __ ] let's talk about
Thanksgiving you guys you guys have an
option no see this is the cool part
right because you guys are the floaters
you can go to whichever one you can stop
by here for a second and it's a mop
somewhere else
want to stay put at one place that's
what I want I don't float during things
because my Thanksgivings prior to this I
always had a float from like three
different homes so I have so many
friends I already have to go to Long
Beach because for my agent side and then
I gotta go and then I gotta go wherever
wherever for this [ __ ] that I'm trying
to relax and be thankful during
Thanksgiving a man was arrested after
barging into multiple homes trying to
get someone to fight him oh my god that
is awesome it sounds like a bark clown
thing I know that's I think I said it
was like me cuz all you're trying to do
is just [ __ ] fight I don't want to
fight anybody so he's just like hi would
you like to fight oh [ __ ] no barging in
aggressively hitting the doorbell you
gave a man in it yeah how do you not die
because they got guns there dude that's
true if someone knocked down my door
that was quite a few states I would
never would shoot that fool immediate
California would probably the ones you
should try it at yeah you should yeah
yeah so this man his name is Christopher
he's 32 years old he was arrested for
numerous offenses including home
invasion battery burglary larceny and
criminal mischief so he began all day
what'd he steal by kicking open a gate
and then he approached a woman who was
sitting outside her mobile home so this
isn't a trailer park and he punched her
in the side of the head oh my god this
was trying to fight everybody it's funny
cuz it's like you're playing grass it's
like you're playing Grand Theft Auto and
you just walk up somebody throw a punch
in the face
that [ __ ] makes me laugh so hard so then
he ended up damaging a ladder and the
exterior door oh poor ladder
poor lady moving on to the next home so
then that's what needs were a wannabe
damage the ladder Daisy like I said do
you wanna [ __ ] fight
and the ladder didn't say anything
he breaks one of the runs a [ __ ]
report this ladder who gives a [ __ ] of
up I think the ladder reported him this
your cop bucket talking to the Lateran
[ __ ] like she's getting us description
so what happened you don't want to talk
I understand I understand that the
traumatic events all right so then she
fell through an open front door and then
one of the residents in China
I'll call Hardy just [ __ ] fell
through they grabbed a hammer and
ordered him to leave so then he left the
trailer park yelling that he would come
back and burn the trailer down Wow and
then he went to a nearby apartment
complex and then he began knocking on an
apartment door and then when a resident
answered pop him in the face this is
when Christopher is now shirtless and he
ends up telling him yelling at him to
fight him so then the resident closed
and locked the door and so that's when
Christopher began to ram the door with
his shoulder causing damage to the door
in the frame oh my god how big is this
guy I'll show you in a minute and then
so deep reme heart you were done to
another residence where he walked in
through the closed but unlocked door and
then he began yelling for the apartments
to male residents to fight him and then
he began to chase the victims around a
table and he was unable to catch them so
he threw a lamp at them and missed then
he grabbed a slice of pizza before
chasing one of the victims into our
bedroom Josh so that's what he was
stealing yep and then he snatched a
landline phone from okay who is landline
anyway Keith black he snatched a
landline phone from the victim who was
trying to call 9-1-1
and then he swung the phone at the
victim several times hitting him once in
the back and you chased the man outside
and around the wall Holly later I know
you can't walk you can't walk past the
pizza a Nazi I agree with you New York
Stalin a full didn't half long oh that's
really smart
I like how they didn't leave that detail
out like here he grabbed the pizza and
he [ __ ] started chasing me if it's
Chicago deep-dish he's like was this
this guy was on bath salts on well I'm
almost done so then he ends up going
outside and running around the apartment
complex before running into a chain
fence knocking it down and passing out
on top of it what the [ __ ] this guy's a
bulldog
maybe you just listen to a Joe Rogan
podcast and he's like I feel like I
could [ __ ] fight it this sounds like
a bet this sounds like an L a crackhead
so then that's when police arrived and
they found him unresponsive like passed
out on top of the fence what a pizza and
then they see that Hugh is seemingly
under the influence of alcohol I don't
buy it I think he was making vague
threats to the clouds during his arrest
Vegas oh he wasn't even like confident
about oh my god he looks like he got
beat in the head a couple of times we
took a nap in the Sun dude what's up
with this hat more so [ __ ] red yeah
what's up with this thing so rad dude he
took a nap in the Sun yeah I mean why
people get red too though yeah yeah yeah
yeah I've seen it
or when they're severe alcoholics
they're just red forever my uncle is no
no or was an alcoholic and yeah he was
always red in the face just because he's
always flash huh yeah damn yeah so this
dude that was his whole thing he was
just drunk trying to get people to fight
him down well is the lady okay that he's
sucked in the side of the neck why don't
have to say it that way I just I'm sorry
no you're right it's like every month it
reminds me of that SNL skit I know right
where they'd like what is it where they
trick you and the guy like you're about
the Eenie just punches you I don't know
where you guys aren't you never saw this
don't worry eat a sandwich
kanakam sandwiches out of people's faces
I don't know if he's not
I don't know yet it sounds like that
jackass one where they hit him with the
[ __ ] big hand I want to know the
jackass one is the water on this side
the rocky way and then he punches that
way have you seen the Land Shark S&L bit
it's similar to this but it's like
there's a door knocker it's like who is
it and it's like oh it's pizza or
whatever I'm like well I hope it's not
that Land Shark I've been hearing about
on the news and he's like no no just a
pizza sir and then they open the door
and a gigantic [ __ ] shark head like
eats them crazy
yeah well the woman she declined to go
to the hospital so she did tell the cops
that she had a brain tumor and would
need thorough medical examination that's
crazy I wonder if this guy is gonna get
back out because that's what happens all
the [ __ ] time and in the until they
finally commit a real severe crime and
they like stay in there for a while
[Music]